هذه الذخائر على المحاك والسبب هذه
المقاطع نعم مقاطع تيك توك قد تهدد تزويد
اوكرانيا بالذخائر شركه نامو لتصنيع
الذخائر النرويجيه احدى اكبر الشركات
المصنعه للذخيره في اوروبا قد لا تتمكن من
تلبيه طلب الاوكرانيين المتزايد على
الذخائر اما السبب فيعود لمركز بيانات تيك
توك الجديد الذي يحتكر ويستهلك الكهرباء
في المنطقه القريبه من اكبر مصنع ذخيره في
النرويج ووفق صحيفه ذا جارديان فان خطط
شركتنا للتوسع تتعارض مع جهود تيك توك
لتحسين صورتها في مواجهه عدد متزايد من
عمليه الحظر في جميع انحاء العالم من خلال
استيعاب بيانات الاوروبيين محليا بشكل
اكبر من بينها النرويج اصلا
وهي خطوه تريد منها تيك توك ارضاء
المشرعين الاوروبيين بتخزين بيانات
المستخدم الاوروبي محليا وتقليل نقل
البيانات خارج المنطقه الشركه اعلنت عن
خطط لفتح مراكز بيانات جديده في ايرلندا
وفي منطقه هامار في النرويج الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه نامو القلق اعتبر ان النمو
المستقبل والحرب الدائره قد يعرقلهما
تخزين مقاطع الفيديو الخاصه بالقطط مثلا